hallo zusammen wir machen heute mal so
ein richtig schönes drei gänge menü und
ich verwöhne den hamza der darf nämlich
alle drei gänge heute probieren und
wirklich kritisch bewerten ich starte
erst mal mit einer vorspeise dann gibt
es ein schönes saftiges steak als
hauptgang und zum abschluss machen wir
noch lava cache und ja wie gesagt
bestanden jetzt einfach und ich habe
euch alles ganz genau hier unten in die
video beschreibung
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt pan konto mate das ist
so ähnlich wie butter aber irgendwie
auch nicht weil wir nehmen uns jetzt
auch ein baguette das ist alles was ich
bin bäcker gekauft habe das ist auch
schon ein bisschen älter und es darf
auch nicht älter sein dass es gar kein
problem
und jetzt werden hier einfach schreiben
runter geschnitten und dann nehmen wir
uns gutes olivenöl ich verlinke euch
mainz in die infobox und werden das
einfach mit olivenöl beträufeln und dann
werde ich es in meiner pfanne von beiden
seiten richtig schön kross anbraten ihr
könnt aber auch wenn ich kein platz auf
dem herd ab könnt ihr das auch im
backofen erledigen
[Musik]
ich mache das galt übrigens parallel in
zwei fallen damit nicht einfach
schneller durch und allgemein das ist
auch jetzt ein schnelles vorspeisen
rezept hoppala und ich gebe jetzt noch
mal oben drüber etwas olivenöl und wird
das gleich noch mal wenden und das
braucht wirklich so von jeder seite 4 k
23 minuten also schaut einfach sonst
richtig schön kross ist und dann kommt
unser schöner tomaten belag obendrauf
dafür nehmen wir uns einfach richtig
schön aromatische tomaten und reiben die
schon fein
[Musik]
ich drehe jetzt die baguette brote hier
um ganz vorsichtig und ich habe die
stufe sieben von neun übrigens und ich
habe jetzt da die tomaten gerieben und
da geb ich gleich noch einen guten
schuss olivenöl mit dazu und ein
bisschen salz und dann ist nämlich der
belag quasi auch schon fertig und man
glaubt gar nicht so wenig zutaten so
eine leckere vorspeise entsteht und das
geheimnis ist dass wir die baguette
brote gleich noch mit frischem knoblauch
einreiben und dann das tomaten topping
obendrauf geben das wird so lecker
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt den hauptgang es gibt
und rico es gibt zwar artig noch
kartoffeln dazu und eine bratensoße ich
würde jetzt auch wenn besuch kommt so
machen was ich mit der bratensoße
beginne weil die kann er ruhig abkühlen
und man kann es immer wieder erwärmen
aber man kann jetzt nicht so ein wie das
fleisch lange im voraus braten oder die
kartoffeln schmecken hat auch am besten
wenn sie frisch aus dem ofen kommen und
salat geht der ruck zuck also für die
soße stehe ich jetzt hier schon am herd
ich habe vor meine zwiebeln schon mal in
feine scheiben geschnitten und jetzt
nehme ich mir meinen olivenöl und wer
die zwiebeln glasig dünsten das dauert
zwei bis drei minuten und dann machen
wir weiter
[Musik]
wenn ihr die zwiebeln dann bei mittlerer
stufe glasig gedünstet hat kommt butter
mit dazu außerdem paprika markt das
sieht dann noch mal so eine gute minute
gerüstet und anschließend geben wir mehr
dazu das sieht einfach dass die masse
später besser bindet und wir fühlen das
ganze mit wasser auf das ganze köchelt
jetzt auch bei mir schon das sieht doch
schon sehr sehr gut aus und es wird
gehört nicht ein bisschen salzig mag
sojasauce dazu und gemüsebrühe und an
gewürzen macht das auch schon mehr
braucht es nämlich gar nicht
unsere blitz bratensoße ist jetzt
eigentlich schon fertig ich las vegas 23
minuten köcheln und dann einfach
beiseiteschieben und wie gesagt die kann
man wunderbar aufwärmen auch am nächsten
tag am übernächsten tag liebe ich diese
soße jetzt mache ich weiter mit den
kartoffeln die komme weil mir gleich in
den ofen und ich mache so typische
rosmarinkartoffeln dafür habe ich hier
so kleine bio kartoffeln da könnt ihr
die schale immer mit verwenden und
entweder könnt ihr es dann halbieren
oder ich glaube ich mache so dass dieses
viertel denn dann brauchen sie auch
nicht so lange im ofen gibt sie dann
direkt auf mein backblech habe ich schon
backpapier unten drunter und dann kommt
da nur olivenöl dazu salz ein bisschen
rosmarin wenn ihr möchtet thymian und
dann wird auch schon gebacken
[Musik]
die ofenkartoffeln brauchen bei 220 grad
umluft ca 30 bis 35 minuten das heißt
wer mit genug zeit um uns um die sachen
zu kümmern ich habe jetzt hier den salat
und ich mache es immer so wenn ich
besuch bekommen ich war schon mal alles
und schnäbel auch alles ich lege dann
auch immer so das meiste zusammen bis
auf die tomaten die schneide ich zwar
auch schon aber lasst sie mir dann
wirklich immer bis zum letzten moment
noch in der schüssel und gibt sie dann
erst dazu denn die western schon sehr
und ich mag meinen salat am liebsten mit
zb feldsalat dann dürfen bei mir rote
zwiebeln fehlen radieschen eigentlich
auch noch kurven aber die habe ich jetzt
nicht da gehabt weil es ist nicht so
schlimm und dann gebe ich noch möhren
dazu und lässt erst mal genauso stehen
denn das dressing kommt jetzt noch nicht
mit dazu sonst würde es komplett durch
wässern das heißt kurz zuvor ich
serviere zeige ich euch mein
allerliebstes dreßen wie aus dem
türkischen restaurant und gebt das
dressing halt noch mit den tomaten dann
mit dazu setzt kommen wir zum fleisch
ich habe hier bei metzger meines
vertrauens an trikot gekauft das ist das
zwischen dritten stück ähnlichem rib eye
steak und eigentlich ist die zubereitung
sehr einfach aber viele trauen sich da
nicht dran ihr braucht auch überhaupt
nicht viele zutaten ihr braucht halt nur
gutes fleisch ihr braucht auch eine gute
fahne ihr wisst ja dass es meine fahne
seit einem jahr schon gibt und die ist
wirklich sehr massiv sehr schwer das ist
eine alu guss fahne und mit der kann ich
wunderbar steak anbraten und die
schritte sind es folgendermaßen ihr
könnt jetzt seit direkt aufs fleisch
geben könnte aber auch später erst
setzen wichtig ist dass wenn ihr es
jetzt schon auf das fleisch gibt dann
sollte es auch zügig in die pfanne und
die fahne sollte auch schon auf
temperatur sein dass ich habe jetzt hier
schon vorgeheizt die wird gerade schön
warm also ich mache es erstmal so dass
ich jetzt vier komplett von beiden
seiten salz und anschließend braucht ihr
auch noch einen hoch erhitzt bares fed
entweder nimmt die butter schmalz oder
andere öle die hoch erhitzt sind ich
nehme hier mein kokosfett das
restaurierte das ist geschmacksneutral
und damit könnt ihr auch sehr sehr heiß
erhitzen
[Musik]
wir braten jetzt das fleisch in der sehr
heißen pfanne von beiden seiten jeweils
eine minute lang an und anschließend
können wir mit der hitze runtergehen ich
habe nur in stufen möglich eine vorstufe
sechs von neun vielleicht auch fünf und
dann braucht es auch nicht mehr lange
und dann zeige ich euch gleich wie wir
das schön aromatisieren können
[Musik]
also ich bin jetzt noch mal runter
gegangen auf stufe vier manchmal bin ich
auf der 5 achtet bitte darauf dass es
wirklich nicht mehr zu heiß ist und um
das ganze jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen
auf ein neues level zu heben könnt ihr
da noch mal ordentlich butter eingeben
ich habe noch einmal frischen rosmarin
rein und ganz viel knoblauch und jetzt
braucht euer fleisch wirklich also je
nach dicke aber wirklich nur noch so
zehn maximal zwölf minuten kommt
natürlich auch darauf an möchtet ihr ist
komplett blutig haben möchtet ihr ist
ein bisschen gaga haben dort haben sie
das nicht so ein fan von blutigen
fleisch ich auch nicht das nimmt ihr
euch quasi diese leckere geschmolzene
butter die ist so aromatisch sind
überdies ist immer wieder fleisch damit
und nach zwölf minuten nehmen wir es
raus und lass uns noch mal in alufolie
gewickelt zehn minuten ruhen das ist
auch ein super wichtiger schritt lasse
es zehn minuten ruhen und dann könnte es
quasi servieren
[Musik]
während das fleisch jetzt nochmal diese
zehn minuten rot nehmen wir uns hier
diesen automatischen rechts und geben
den in unsere sauce mit rein ich fange
jetzt nochmal knoblauch und rosmarin auf
und somit haben wir unsere bratensoße
auch noch mal auch so ein richtig neues
level gebracht und eigentlich ist dann
alles zeitgleich fertig ich mache nur
noch das dressing und das besteht aus
olivenöl granatapfel dürfte nimmt er am
besten 100 prozentigen mein verlinkt ich
euch auch hier unten in der infobox dann
braucht es nur noch ein bisschen
apfelessig salz und wenn ihr mögt zu mag
das ist es sich baum gewürzt und das
schmeckt so ein bisschen die
pulverisierte es sich also schmeckt auch
richtig gut
[Musik]
lego final wir machen jetzt lava
küchlein und sind wir mal ehrlich gibt
es auf dieser welt irgendjemanden der
lagerküche nicht mag dieser mensch ist
in meinen augen nicht normal wir werden
etwas mal kuvertüre und butter schmelzen
peter kuvertüre ich weiß es gibt einige
unter euch die sind kein pfad bitterfeld
aber sie schmeckt es am ende jetzt nicht
wirklich raus sondern es ist halt
einfach super intensiv schokoladig
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die schokoladenmasse
einmal schmelzen lassen das habe ich
über dem wasserbad gemacht einfach damit
da nichts verbrannt und damit das
wirklich so es muss vor sich hin schmelz
und nicht zu schnell schmidt und das
gebe ich jetzt kurz an die seite für
zehn bis 15 minuten das muss nämlich
runterkühlen damit dass gleich nicht
stoppt sonst haben wir nämlich rührei
und ich muss jetzt aber die zwischenzeit
und bereitet diese förmchen vor entweder
nimmt die förmchen oder was ich halt
auch immer gemacht habe einfach
hitzebeständige kaffeetassen könnt ihr
auch super gerne verwenden und wir
bereiten das jetzt vor indem wir hier
ein bisschen zimmer warme butter nehmen
auf dem pinsel und dann streitig die
förmchen komplett damit aus und damit
ich halt auf nummer sicher gehen dass
die törtchen gleich auch wirklich
rauskommen und nicht irgendwo dran
kleben bleiben nehme ich mir gleich noch
backpapier und kleide wirklich nur den
boden damit aus
[Musik]
so die förmchen sind vorbereitet und wir
machen zwei damit unserer schoko masse
ich nehme jetzt hier erstmal die eier
dafür brauchen wir bringen eine separate
schüsse und wir brauchen keine geräte
kein handrührgerät gerne küchenmaschine
alles die sie heute zu den eiern gebe
ich jetzt noch zucker und vanille exakt
und verrührt das erst mal komplett damit
sich alles miteinander verbindet
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die kuvertüre massa
erstmal in dem dünnen strahl mit dazu
gegeben schön gerührt und habe ich alles
dazu gegeben und es hat sich das schon
miteinander verbunden und jetzt fehlt
nur noch für eine kleine bindung wir
wollen zu den flüssigen kern aber eine
kleine bindung muss es haben und dafür
nämlich mail und es sich mit dazu und
wir brauchen wir natürlich kein
backpulver denn das wäre nicht so
förderlich für unseren kern
[Musik]
ich habe den ofen vorgeheizt 200 grad
ober und unterhitze und was ich euch
auch sagen wir ich denke die frage kommt
bestimmt auch ihr könnt das auch
vorbereitungen zum besuch empfangen und
er möchte es natürlich frisch servieren
dann macht den teig einfach so weit
fertig ihr könnt ihr dann auch sehr
gerne im kühlschrank lagern dass es gar
kein problem wenn ich zum beispiel
morgens werde ich noch ein arzt aus bad
und die vorbereiteten förmchen werden
jetzt gefüllt
[Musik]
hansa das ist die vorspeise nehmen wir
gern das weg ist egal welches ich liebe
ja alle gleich ich bin gerne gleich
so das ist jetzt ein konto mate das ist
wirklich eine locker leichte vorspeise
und du merkst du schon richtig viel
knoblauch aus das ist dieses ein reihe
mit knoblauch
ich denke du willst knoblauch uni will
weg ich so lieder vorspielen also
vorspeise zehn von zehn ganz ehrlich
sind ziehen falls
er sich auf sein olivenöl verwendet so
schön ist wirklich sehr auf ja dann dass
es dir schmeckt man dann geht es weiter
mit dem hauptgang uhr hauptgang und rico
mit bratensoße und rosmarinkartoffeln
das nennt sich so das heißt also ich hab
auch schon am gerade im video gesagt
haben sein mag das nicht so blutig auch
nicht mal rosa nicht mal ansatzweise
rosa deswegen musste ich es grad noch
mal für ihn ein bisschen länger warten
lassen
beschreibt euch so deine gefühle beim
essen im restaurant wie viele sterne
super lecker also ich jetzt also das
alles zusammen das ist nun ja nur
auswärts eigentlich ja zu hause kriegen
das meint nicht so gut wenn jemand denkt
das ist schwer ich finde das richtig
richtig wenn man das delikate league das
ist das besondere aber ist so
ungeschminkt nachdem entspricht noch
lecker ja das also ich werde in dem
einst denke man sicher nicht jeden tag
selbst stimmt und die kommen jetzt aus
dieser zwiebelsoße was ist da drin
tomaten paprika mal kaputt da passt
richtig guten der kartoffel als völlig
frei
die punktevergabe sei ehrlich ist es
nicht schön wenn im nächsten punkte geht
es ist schwerer die hier mitmachen zu
geben hier sollen salat da kommen leute
das ist bestimmt auch mit becker gewürzt
war so schön denkt jetzt bei uns fünf
mal die woche endlich ehrlich so
irgendwann dieses dressing ja ich liebe
das so gibt es ja dann hast lass es den
ro schmecken soll zurückkommen wird
kommt dass der rothenbaum mit einer
goldenen schaufel bitte trinkgeld
gegeben ja online service hier das ist
eine schokolade
kuchen und jetzt kommt der witz ist
aufgebaut fürs foto ich hab das vor
lässt du dich unser video vor über drei
jahren in der alten küche wir machen
einen schokoladen lava kuchen das ist
das rezept ich sag dir die rezepte sind
perfekt ich muss sie gar nicht verändern
und
ein traum von schokolade und also punkte
10 10 in hama jetzt wollte ich rannte
ich habe ziemlich drauf und er abgeholt
meint man trainer geworden als ich bin
auch wenn gäste kommen ist einfach ein
perfektes menü ihr müsst nichts mehr
dazu machen war leckere getränke noch
und fertig
[Musik]
eine lehrstelle doch einen tipp dadurch
dass wir ja auch fotos und entsehen
machen er ist ja halt leicht abgekühlt
einfach in der mikrowelle hast du gar
nicht gemerkt ist einfach in die
mikrowelle 40 50 sekunden und der
schmeckt wäre richtig schön
alles alles machen wir wünschen uns ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und hoffen
dass ich das video gefeiert haben sehr
sehr viel mühe gegeben wenn ihr diese
mühe schätzt den rechten daumen nach
oben unten kommentar hier unten um den
algorithmus ein bisschen zu pushen und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
mal
[Musik]